What's up global citizens i'm Ollie and
today we are learning English with the
classic story of Cinderella. Now there are
many different versions of this fairy tale
but one of the most well-known is the animation
from Disney from the 1950's and did you know that
in 2015 it was made into a movie? If you've seen
this movie let me know in the comments below.
In this lesson we're gonna watch two scenes from
the 2015 movie and I'm going to teach you some
vocabulary and then at the end you're going to
have the opportunity to watch the two scenes
without subtitles and I'm going to quiz you
with some questions. So make sure you watch
all of this lesson to test yourself at the
end. But before we get started I want to
tell you that we help you understand fast English
without getting lost, without missing the jokes
and without subtitles. Just ask Anna Victoria who
says she is now watching movies without subtitles.
So take your English to the next level like Anna
Victoria. It's really simple, all you need to do
is hit that subscribe button and the bell down
below so you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Cinderella tells the story of an orphan girl
who is made a servant by her stepmother and
stepsisters. One day the king invites
all the single ladies in the kingdom
to come to a ball so that the prince can choose
one to be his wife. In hopes to attend the ball
Cinderella along with the help of the house mice
fix an old dress of her late mother. But then.
If you love disney movies then make
sure you check out this playlist.
We've made lessons with Ratatouille,
Maleficent, Soul and much more.
So despite her stepmother forbidding her
to go to the ball, Cinderella is helped by
the house animals and the fairy godmother and
eventually makes it to the ball. Importantly,
she must return to her house by midnight.
Otherwise the people at the ball will
realize that she is not a royal personage
and can you imagine? Her stepmother would
be outraged if she sees her there while
at the ball she dances with the prince.
However when the clock strikes 12 she runs out of
the palace leaving behind only a crystal slipper.
If you want to learn more about connecteed speech
then I highly recommend our Fluent with Friends
Course. In this 48 week Course you're gonna
learn with the first two seasons of Friends
each week you will receive PDF power
lessons, Vocabulary Memorization Software,
lifetime access to our Fluency Circle Global
Community and so much more! To learn more
all you need to do is click up here
or down in the description below
Alrighty do you remember at the start
I said you're going to have a quiz?
Well it's time for that. So we're going to
watch the two scenes again without subtitles
and there's going to be a couple of questions
in there that you will need to answer. Let me
know if you get all the questions correct
down in the comments below and don't forget
to hit that subscribe button and the bell down
below so you don't miss any of our new lessons.